on normandy's Coast the small town of
ETA and its Majestic White Cliffs Evelyn
vel's lived in the area most of her life
and she says she never tires of its
natural
beauty there are lots of caves and
grottos there's a mystery to ET which
draws people
here once a fishing port it's now
tourism that fuels the local economy
but's popularities led to thousands of
visitors crowding its streets and Cliff
paths each day ruining the quality of
life for residents and threatening the
environment Evelyn says tourists are
welcome but more needs to be done to
minimize their
impact it's complicated for us there are
long cues to buy bread or to drive
anywhere people take the Pebbles from
the beach they feed the seagulls so
visitors need to be informed about what
they can do and we residents need to
find out better ways to host them French
impressionist artists painted at today
it's mainly mobile phones that capture
its aore on Whirlwind visits I'm from
China yeah because this a famous place
to tourist so we come here and how long
are you going to spend here today uh
we're only two days at of here for us
it's the first time in France in general
um and um we spend uh um 5 days in Paris
before we come here it's a similar
picture elsewhere in France in High
season overrun sites and packed beaches
France is the world's most visited
country but so-called over tourism is a
real problem for many regions which is
why the French government have now
launched a new plan to try and better
manage tourist
flows hiring influencers to promote
lesser known destinations in France and
helping local authorities to better COPE
in tourist hotspots are among the
measures France is a big tourist nation
France loves tourism and tourists France
will never stop people going to mon
Melle or Eiffel Tower but the reality is
when you look at the amount of people
it's clear we'll need to introduce a
limit on visitor numbers improving the
visitor experience while respecting
local communities and protecting the
environment is a delicate balance but
one that needs to be found to safeguard
France's architectural and natural
heritage for future Generations Natasha
Butler Al jazer ET Normandy
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al
jazer